supongamos que estás interesado en los
hábitos de ver televisión de la gente en
particular que tanto la gente de
televisión en el país y lo que tienes
que tomar en cuenta si imaginamos a
todos los habitantes del país esto ya lo
hemos hablado especialmente si estamos
hablando de un país como los eeuu aunque
cualquier país va a tener una gran
población en eeuu estamos hablando
alrededor de 300 millones de habitantes
idealmente si de alguna manera mágica
pudieras hacerlo tendrías que observar o
encuestar a las 300 millones de personas
y calcular la media de cuánto tiempo de
televisión ven en un día específico eso
te va a dar el parámetro la media
poblacional pero esto también ya lo
hemos hablado antes encuestar a toda la
población es sin práctico aunque
pudieras hacerlo en el momento en que
terminarás de tomar los datos te darás
cuenta que algunas personas han muerto
otras habrán nacido quien sabe que
tantas cosas habrán ocurrido de tal
manera que aunque existe un valor
verdadero de esta media poblacional
teórica del tiempo en que los americanos
se la pasan viendo la televisión en un
día específico aunque en un momento dado
existe un valor real un valor real en un
momento dado específico la realidad es
que es imposible obtener ese valor
específico aunque existe es imposible
obtener dicho valor verdadero pero no te
das por vencido y dices bien en lugar de
observar a las 300 millones de personas
voy a obtener una muestra simplemente
voy a tomar una muestra a partir de esta
población y pongamos que con objeto de
hacer los cálculos simples tomamos una
muestra de tamaño 6 posteriormente
hablaremos de por qué una muestra de
tamaño 6 no tiene el tamaño adecuado que
se requiere así que preguntas cuánto
tiempo en televisión estas personas y
encuentras que una persona a la de una
hora y media otra persona a la de dos
horas y media alguien más de 4 horas de
televisión otra persona ve dos horas de
televisión y dos personas ven una hora
cada una así es que dados estos datos de
la muestra que es lo que obtenemos como
media muestra bien la media muestral la
cual denotamos con una equis
con una raya encima es simplemente la
suma de los valores de la muestra
dividida entre el número de datos de la
muestra que tenemos en este caso 1.5 2.5
más 4 más dos más uno más uno dividido
entre seis esto es igual a 1.5 2.5 es
igual a 44 igual a 8 más 2 es igual a 10
más 2 es igual a 12 dividido entre 6 12
sextos lo que es igual a 2 horas de
televisión por lo tanto para tu muestra
puedes afirmar que la media muestral es
de 2 horas de televisión es un estimado
es un estadístico que trata de estimar
este parámetro que es muy difícil de
conocer sin embargo lo mejor que tenemos
quizás podríamos tener una mejor
aproximación con más datos pero por lo
pronto esto es lo que tenemos y ahora lo
siguiente que te preguntas es bueno no
simplemente quiero obtener la media
poblacional también quiero obtener otro
parámetro quiero obtener otro parámetro
estoy interesado también en obtener la
varianza poblacional
nueva cuenta dado que no podemos
encuestar a toda la población esto es
prácticamente imposible conocer vamos a
estimar este parámetro que intentamos
estimar la media y ahora vamos a
intentar estimar este parámetro este
parámetro denominado varianza y cómo le
hacemos bueno lo razonable es pensar que
hagamos con la muestra lo mismo que
hacemos con la población para calcular
la varianza poblacional tomás cada uno
de los valores individuales le restas la
media poblacional elevada al cuadrado
esa diferencia sumas todos esos
cuadrados de las diferencias y lo
divides entre el número de datos que se
tienen hagamos eso aquí tomamos cada uno
de estos valores
calculamos la diferencia déjame hacerlo
con un color distinto tomamos cada uno
de los valores
cada uno de estos valores y le restamos
la media muestral no la media
poblacional que no conocemos la media
muestral le restamos la media muestral
lo elevamos al cuadrado más el siguiente
nuestros valores que es 4 menos 2 al
cuadrado más el siguiente valor uno
menos 2 elevado al cuadrado y esto lo
que hubiéramos hecho si tuviéramos que
calcular la varianza poblacional
suponiendo que ésta fuera nuestra
población encontraríamos la media de
esta población obtendríamos la distancia
de cada punto con respecto a la media lo
elevaría mos al cuadrado
la sumaríamos y la dividiríamos entre el
número de puntos luego tenemos más 2.5
menos 2 le estamos restando la media
muestral elevamos al cuadrado más déjame
hacerlo con este verde más dos menos 2
elevado al cuadrado y finalmente más uno
más uno menos dos elevado al cuadrado
y eso lo dividimos entre el número total
de puntos que en este caso es 6 que
tenemos entonces tenemos como primer
término 1.5 2.5 elevado al cuadrado
punto 5 elevado al cuadrado obtenemos
punto 25 0.25 luego 4 menos dos elevado
al cuadrado esto es 4 4 - 2 es 2 eleva
al cuadro es 41 menos 2 es menos 1 - 1
elevado es 1 luego 2.5 menos 12.5
elevado al 4.25
2 - 12 0 al cuadrado es 0 y finalmente 1
- 2 - 1 - 1 elevado al cuadrado menos 1
elevado al cuadrado es 1 positivo
hagamos la suma tenemos que punto 25 es
el primero los enteros 4 1 del 5 y 1 son
6 6 y aquí tenemos punto 25.25 86.5 esto
es igual a hacerlo con otro color esto
es igual a 6.5 dividido entre este 6 y
6.5 entre 6 y esto podemos escribir lo
bueno hay distintas maneras de cómo
escribir esto voy a sacar la calculadora
esto es igual a 6.5 sobre 6
esto me da igual a 1.08 1.08 redondeado
así que esto es igual a esto es
aproximadamente igual a 1.08 bien es lo
que obtenemos de este cálculo lo que
tenemos que pensar ahora es si este es
en realidad el mejor cálculo
si dado los datos con que se cuentan es
esta la mejor estimación para la
varianza poblacional con estos datos que
se tienen aquí siempre puedes argumentar
que con más datos se obtendría una mejor
estimación pero dados estos datos es
esta la mejor estimación que se tiene
para la varianza poblacional piense en
esto brevemente
resulta que esta es una estimación
cercana bastante cercana a la mejor
estimación que se puede hacer dados los
datos con los que se cuenta este es un
tipo particular de varianza que se tiene
en la cual se divide entre el número de
datos con el que se cuenta así es que
usualmente la gente escribe una n como
subíndice aquí así es que esta es una
manera de calcular la varianza muestral
como un intento de aproximar la varianza
poblacional pero resulta y en el
siguiente vídeo te voy a dar una
explicación intuitiva del por qué esto
es así e inclusive voy a escribir una
simulación por computadora para que
podamos experimentalmente apreciar mejor
este hecho pues resulta entonces que se
obtiene una mejor aproximación de la
varianza poblacional si en vez de
dividir entre seis el número de datos
que se tienen divides entre el número de
datos que se tienen menos uno y cómo
hacemos eso bien vamos a denotar la
varianza y cuando la mayoría de la gente
habla de varianza muestral se están
refiriendo a la varianza de la
que incluye estos cálculos pero en vez
de dividir en 36 se divide entre 5 en
este caso denotamos que se divide entre
n 1 que nos resulta entonces en este
caso bueno el numerador es exactamente
el mismo que obtuvimos aquí el numerador
es igual a 6.5 y en el denominador
tenemos n que es igual a 6 tenemos 6
datos pero ahora vamos a dividir entre n
menos 16 menos 1 lo cual es igual a 5
así que 6.5 entre 5 es igual a 1.3 pues
resulta que esta técnica para calcular
la varianza de la muestra es la más
común aunque parece un poco de brujería
porque dividimos entre de menos 1
mientras que para la varianza
poblacional dividimos entre n pero
recuerda estamos tratando de estimar la
varianza poblacional y esta es una mejor
estimación y porque esto es así este
cálculo está subestimando la varianza
poblacional
esta es una mejor estimación no sabemos
precisamente cuáles ambos cálculos
podrían estar muy alejados pudo haber
sido simplemente el azar debido a la
muestra pero cuando tomas un gran número
de muestras y hay varias maneras de ver
esto
es un mejor cálculo esto te va a dar una
mejor estimación pero ahora como
escribimos esto cómo podemos escribir
esto en notación matemática bien
recuerda que estamos calculando una suma
estamos tomando la suma sobre cada uno
de nuestros datos empezamos en el primer
dato y concluimos en el enésimo dato
estamos usando en minúscula pues nos
estamos refiriendo a la muestra si
hubiera sido en mayúscula nos estaríamos
refiriendo a toda la población
aquí estamos considerando una muestra de
tamaño n minúscula estamos tomando cada
punto x subíndice y le estamos restando
la media la muestra estamos restando la
media de la muestra estamos elevando al
cuadrado estamos tomando la suma del
cuadrado de las distancias y estamos
dividiendo no entre el número de datos
sino en el número de datos menos uno así
que esta fórmula que tenemos aquí donde
dividimos entre 5 en vez de dividir
entre 6
la definición común de la varianza de la
muestra vamos a dejarlo aquí en el
siguiente vídeo
voy a intentar despertar tu intuición
del por qué estamos dividiendo entre n
en vez de entre n 1